[Music]
i was
crossing the border with the thought
that i'm never going back home i
actually thought that i'm saying goodbye
to my dad forever and i'm not gonna see
him again
he told us to
go somewhere in europe like to
start our lives there
to like go to university somewhere to
find a job and just live our lives there
i was at a sleepover with my friend and
we woke up at like five because her mom
called us and she's like
wake up girls the world has started like
what
there were a lot of uh airplanes flying
by our building
and then i remember when i woke up the
next day and i'm like oh it was just a
scary it was just a nightmare you know
ukraine was attacked they decided to go
we didn't know where we didn't know who
will take us
we packed in literally an hour when we
were leaving like closing the house i
remember i was looking at my room my
pets are still there at my home but i
didn't know if i'm gonna see them again
i don't know if i'm gonna see them i
don't know if i'm gonna see my dad again
what i took with myself was like couple
of pants couple of shirts
that's it all this material stuff like
laptops like houses cars everything like
loses its sense after you packing just
one backpack to flee from warm
there's like a lot of stress a lot of
mess going on in your mind a lot of
thoughts
recording
uh everything and saying something on
the camera helped me to put every my
thoughts on in the order
i'm here with my mom and my sister
and my closest friends
okay that's my mom mom
there were bombing in my hometown in my
village
i know there's a couple of peoples died
because of bombs and i know that
there is
several families
are right now
without their homes because it got
destroyed
uh i don't know what my life what my
life will look like when i
get back home i don't know
if i ever will go back home every time
the
air airplane flies by i'm like i'm
thinking like there's gonna be a bomb
from it
like to every loud sound i'm like i'm
boring and i'm i like i feel like i have
to hide somewhere
they say
time heals but when it's warm
i don't think it works like that
you